スリー・ツー・ワン　Go シュイッ　シュイッ　シュイッ
イテテテテェェェェッ!
あれ?どこいった?
こんにちは。はじめしゃちょーです。
ベイブレード
ちょっとあのしばらくサボってて、全然やってなかったんですけども、
なんか久しぶりにアニメとか、なんか新型のベイブレード見たら
めっちゃかっこよくて（（いいなぁ
トゥンク
ちょっとトゥンクしちゃいまして、ちょっとまたベイブレードちょっと「やりてぇー」って思っちゃって、ちょっと
このやる気がすごい出てきて
最近のかっこいいいんですよ
なんかどんどんイカつくなってきてて、
めちゃくちゃちょっとおしゃれな感じになってきてて
そろそろちょっと復帰しようと思って、ベイブレードはじめようと思ってぇ
事件は起きてしまったのです
俺はあやっ!
まぁ、そんなすごい話じゃないですよ
全然そんなすごい話じゃないんですけども
僕からしたら
エッ!　エッ!　エッ!
ってなるくらいちょっとびっくりしたというか
ちょっと心の中で
シャッッ!
って感じだったんで、ちょっと
そう、新型のベイブレード買おうと思ってそのベイブレード買ったんですよ
ごめんね。袋すっげぇボロボロ
そう、なんかアニメ見ててもすっげぇかっこよかったんすよね
アニメの主人公のライバルが使っているベイブレード分かるんですけども
めっっちゃかっこよくないですか？
僕、赤とか黄色が好きなんで
もう、すごいまわりがキラキラしてて
って見てみ。全ての能力が融合！
もう、1番強いやんっていうか、もうなんか
まあ、いろいろあって全部混ざってる最強のベイブレードみたいな
全機能搭載って、もう1番強いやん
嘘！
すげぇ
だから、そんなねもう、ぱとっ見ぜってぇこれ強いやんっていうレベルで見つけたんで
すぐ買おうと思って買ったんですよ
でもね、これねぇもう普通のお店だとなかなか売ってなくて
これもうAmazonで買うしかないなって思ってAmazonで買いました
Amazonで見ても結構高いんっすよ！
まぁ、だいたい2,300円ぐらいなんですけども、それでもベストセラーですごい売れてて
やっぱ人気の商品だなって思いまして
かっこよくて強そうだから使いたいなっ思って、買って届くの楽しみに待って、待って、待って
ようやく届いたわけなんですよ！
箱をパカッとやって中身を空けてみると、
...
おいおいおいおいw
オッホイッ！
オイオイオイ
Why?
待って待って待って待って
僕は赤色の
赤色のこのスプリガンレクイエム、普通のやつが欲しかったのに
開けてみたら
ヴぉェンブルブルブルブルブルッ
何でェェェェッッッ！！
オイ何でだよォ！
ッざけんなよォォェェェッ
って思ったんですけど
この中の紙見てみると、なんかこんなのが入ってまして
超レアカラーバージョンおめでとうございます
こちらの商品は、スプリガンレクイエムに低確率で封入されている超レアカラーバージョンです
...
クゥッ!
えぇ～何?
聞いてない聞いてない聞いてない。全然ベイブレードのこと何にも今知らないから分かんないし
これどうやらすげぇ激レアの超レアカラーバージョンのベイブレードでらしいでございます
いやいや、使いづれぇよ
いや、すごいな!
いやっっw
あざっす!
本当にレアらしいんですよ
ちょっとどれぐらいレアなのかちょっと調べてみますか
封入率、当選というかこのブラックバージョンが入っている確率は
1/72ってぱっと聞きなんかすごい高そうに見えるんですけども
単純に言うと72個買うと1個当たっている計算になります
なのでAmazonでもし、このスプリガンレクイエム買おうとすると1個2,300円ぐらいなんで
2300掛ける72、165,000円...かかっちゃいますwww
たまたまスプリガンレクイエム買って1個買ってあけてみたらすごい激レアの
色違いのベイブレードが当たってしまった...みたいでございます
ア゛タッ
...
ッしゃあッッ!!
いや、普通にうれしいです
普通にうれしいですし
はっ!
値段が気になるなぁ～
ふつうのスプリガンレクイエムは1,500円ぐらいで売っていますね。普通にネットとか
うわっ! あっ!
はっ!
おうっ! おっ! はっ!はっ!はっ!はっ!はっ!はっ!はっ!はっ!
はぁッ!はぁッ!はぁッ!はぁッ!
(バタン)
ひはっひはっひはっッッッ!!!!
ウ゛ぅるるるッ!!
こんな高いん?
よくわかんない。よくわかんないっすけど
このパーツだけ今値段見たんですけど、
だいたい22,980円とかで売ってました
ウ゛ェッフッ!
たぶんこれ割高だと思います。そんな高いことないでしょう。
うわっ!　でも、まあまあまあ
だいたい10,000円は超えてますね
Amazonだと何円だろ？
いやぁっっハッ!!
やばっ!
残り1個しか無いんですけど
14,000円で売られております
大切にしよう
いや、マジ大切にしよ。絶対俺売らねぇ
てか、なんかすごいね。運命を感じました。久しぶりに。
売らないですけど、なんかちょっと保存とかして飾っておく用的なやつなのかな?
いやぁ、使おう!
ベイブレードって回すためにありますからね
(心臓の鼓動)
ふっ!　ふっ!　ふっ!　ふっ! 　ふっ!　ふっ!
スリー・ツー・ワン　Go シュート
(がたがたがたっ)
大事!!
かっこいいな、でも
なんかね赤色が好きなんですけども、ちゃんと真ん中も赤いし別にいいやって思ってきました
それでもなんか...ねぇ、2,000円のもの買って、届いて開けてみたら
14,000円のものがはいってたっていう12,000円のaddでした
しゃぁっ!!
（無言）